I just want to start with how much I've
really been enjoying your work and it's
fantastic in this movie and I just
appreciate what you're doing oh thanks
man thank you that means a lot
I have a ton of questions about a
variety of subjects so here we go
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
you know what this one punches because
um
I I yeah it's truly like such a um
you know it's it's a it's in
you know I I just sat there and
interviewed that um it was you know kind
of it's nice to get a player
and I the character that has such an
innocent and honest and and truthfully
you know demeanor about him and rather
than the Sinister kind of thing that
we're gonna use to
um that's actually I think harder to
play that as well you know to to be nice
and like even innocent
um I'm curious what of the roles you've
done uh which is the one that you
prepared for the most
before filming began obviously oh so
does it there's a level of you know prep
that I do on every film you know given
and it doesn't mold scans involved which
you know I write down some character
questions and you know I used to get my
granny to write character questions I'd
say look pretend you don't know this
person I want you to list a bunch of
questions and I'm going to answer them
you know and then I'd have an element of
you know images and and kind of you know
drawings around that time and kind of an
image board and then I could have a
moleskin book on you know experiences
that relate to my experiences you know
character experiences that are similar
to mine so I could kind of draw from
that and I then took it all out the
window but the one I done the most would
for would be probably the one I just
finished which is salt porn
um which Emerald's funnel directed but
between that and you know and Martin's
and you know jorgas's film I think I'm
so curious because again I I am a big
fan of your work
um if you have a huge scene on a Monday
you know it's going to be emotional or
dramatic or you know it's really a scene
that you want to deliver on how early on
are you preparing for that scene is it
like oh you know weeks out you're
thinking about it or do you like hyper
focus on Saturday
I mean you're always kind of thinking of
these things when you get the schedule
at all right when's that scene okay cool
but I tend not to focus on it too much
because I really do
like to be you know spontaneous I really
do like to try and again I'm I'm maybe
saying I'm so ridiculous here you know
but react you know you can't prep how
you're gonna react
and and that for me is you know it's
just all about going and just you know
if there's certain things you have to
hit like a certain Mark and Etc well
then you'll rehearse that but in terms
of how I'm gonna react I can't I don't
like to preempt I like it to be fresh
and real and you know and behave if if I
can um so I tend not to focus too much
on these heavy scenes and just know what
I'm doing and you know show up and throw
all of the window
sometimes when I draw all of the window
I actually forget what I'm supposed to
say I try that much out the window
s
it's funny because I've spoken to a lot
of actors and some will talk about how
exactly what you said where they don't
want to have any emotion before they
step on set and others uh who are hyper
um uh like rehearsals will start at the
like you know months out they'll start
thinking about every aspect so it's just
so interesting there's no right way to
get to it you know and again you know
even with methods and you know and here
if this person is a method actor and
that person is a method actor I mean
it's you know I haven't written on my
phone and my book my diary it's called
My Method and that's what I go boy is my
method what works for me and you know
and and that's the way I've always done
it I don't want to be out there trying
to be like so-and-so or like so-and-so
here you know they've done it they've
done it their way and and that's how
they are where they are I want to do my
way and and that I don't even know what
that is
you know I mean that is you know I don't
think anyone kind of knows what they do
and you don't want to know what you are
doing and you want to kind of keep it
fresh and learn and fail and
so yeah if all that makes sense no 100
it's how you contribute myself over and
over again though no no I totally get it
I heard you were a big fan of Martin's
work and you had a picture of him on
your phone
um and so what did it mean to you to
actually you know have him say hey um
you know I want you for this
it was you know it's it's insane how
would the Law of Attraction works and
I'm not one of these for like picture a
car and you'll get the car or you know
that commercial or version of it it's
more about content and so on you know
and and it's I I grew up with my nanny
who's um you know raises quite
religiously as well and you know I I I
drop a prayer here and there as well and
and that's it and I feel feel very
blessed in a lot of sense and well I I
think that in combination with the
Universe I think you know if you put it
out there you also got to work hard for
it you know you don't just put it out
there and expect it and you put it out
there and you work hard for it and I
think it's more about attracting the
opportunities more than is about
attracting the actual thing it is you
want so when you get the opportunity
then it shows then you gotta go work for
it and so yeah I had Martin on the front
of my phone and for like you know months
I was I was in New York I was living in
New York and
and I'm staying with a friend he said
why have you got him on the front of
your phone he actually thought it was
Sting I was like nah it's Mark McDonald
and then he um he I remember Martin
texted me then uh well emailing me and
saying and you know I'd love you to be a
part of my movie I was like oh my God
Mark McDonald just emailed me so I went
and met him up in Midtown in New York
and
up until literally he walked in I
remembered I should take him off my
phone he was still on the front of it so
he would have been sitting there and he
would have seen his face pop up and
whatever this kid is insane but um yeah
I told him and he laughed about him
whatever but you know that is just one
one of the things that um I tend to do
and I mean it's that kind of thing if
you want something just go fight for it
you know or go you know if it's not
right it's not right for you but you
know I'm not a believer in sitting and
expecting and waiting for stuff to
happen for me I can't imagine being such
a fan and then getting cast in the movie
uh did you put your did you put like any
extra pressure on yourself for those
first few days on set when Martin is
first getting to know you and watching
you work do you know what I mean like a
little more in your head
yeah you will be I mean that's what any
director kind of yelling especially
anyone that you admire
um you're like the forest lion the force
kind of thing is always um
you're like am I gonna be recast or you
know but when you when I done it and you
say oh great I'm like oh great okay pass
that then you know but uh I think that's
what keeps you going and keeps you on
top of your game is you what you you
know he's bringing you on to this movie
to bring a certain level of something so
you know you gotta show up with that I
thought listen the movie's fantastic
what was it like actually can you talk a
little bit about like is there a day or
two that you'll always remember from
being on set with Colin or Brendan or
Martin just one of those days that
you'll you know what I mean like
especially yeah there is many of them
days always with Colin always you know
chats we get into and stuff like that I
remember one day with Brendan and
Brendan likes to play the violin I
remember there was a group of Irish
dancers I think they're you know and we
were all waiting in the tent wind has
gone insane we're on the on the coast
you couldn't be any more Irish and
Brendan starts playing the violin and
Wonderland start you know dancing away
and I'm just like
hell man you know
this is insane but you know totally
wrapped up in that
traditional Iris kind of culture that
music and you know and Brendan is just
it's just fascinating what a man as well
you know
um just to be amongst that and watch you
know apart from making this movie we
were involved in this little thing here
you know it was yeah uh you've worked
with a number of very talented
filmmakers and I'm curious who is the
most relaxed on set and who is the one
that is always hyper focused and like
guard rails on you know not joking
around
God am I gonna get into trouble here
um well I'm not trying to get you in
trouble but you know what I mean not to
say that if you're not like super
serious that you're not a good director
so no but um they all are I mean they
all have their own seriousness about
them and their own way of getting
something across you know and you know
and that that is what makes makes some
great directors not only that they make
great films but how they communicate
with their actors and that so um you
know yogas is great and and you know
very you know to the point of you know
stay still and stop moving and you know
and emerald is very she'll come off the
end she'll she'll go through the scene
which in the beat switching and and
Martin is is a great way of you know you
know just humanizing the characters
that's the best way I can put that
wherever he does he you know gets that
crossy that makes this person real
rather than playing you know the kind of
animated version of it or whatever and
and then Christopher Nolan is you know
you know very you know you're on you
know Christopher no one said so that
says oh and they all have their own ways
they all have their own ways but I have
a great understanding of you know the
actors and actresses and and how they
communicate with them and I'm very
very and gentle so what is Martin like
in terms of the notes he gives you on a
performance say you're filming a scene
you're doing something with Colin what
is the does he give you like a long note
or does he pull you aside and say a
little less or like what what is he like
in terms of the notes we had that thing
as well we were like you know I'd go a
bit big and he'd be like less less you
know and and you know when you direct uh
approaches you with a smile and it's a
genuine smile you know and he's not just
trying to get the day going on and you
know all right we have to move on you
know when Martin's happy that is the
best feeling in the world like you know
it's just insane like because you know
you are in safe hands with Martin and
you know and wherever you saying that
dialogue and whatever whatever the beats
are you know that you are in good good
hands so when he is happy he's the best
film in the world uh Colin and Brendan
are phenomenal actors what is it like as
an actor do you are you always looking
at other people's performances that you
admire for like little things that you
can borrow in terms of the way they work
on set or you know what I mean like
because it's like getting a master class
up close it is you know funny you said
that I was actually when I was doing the
scene I was like you know I'm with
Brendan Grayson confirm and Kerry you
know and Facebook scratches but like you
know they are Ireland's going on if you
get me that's you know to be in that
crew and that that company is just
Amaze on Martin as well like you know
watching him direct them I remember I
was just I think it was the pope scene
where I wasn't really into that much but
I was there and I was watching all of
them you know go back and forth
I know she was there was that moment of
you know you are witnessing you know a
master class here but in terms of
borrowing
you know you're always just kind of
looking for
I'm always looking for the
what's what's the kind of
you know
what what is it what is it that we're
trying to do that's
that we can get across that is the most
makes the audience relate so much you
know is it being rise of being real is
it being you know vulnerable what is it
like I'm trying to figure that out you
know is it the behaving part is it you
know I'm always trying to figure it out
and that's the beauty of it as well is
I'm always trying to you know learn from
from from the craft and what it is that
that we do how can we take a another
level up
and so I'm always watching
I'm always watching I am really looking
forward to Masters of the air
um which is another thing that you've
done
um what can you tease people about it I
can't really say that much about it and
other than you know and get to work with
us and and Collins and it was amazing as
well
um you know but I can't really go into
details
I don't want to I don't want to spoil
anything I think it's um
yeah no it's totally fine
um obviously uh I am so curious what you
can talk about and what can you can
reminisce about working with Matt Reeves
because I am a huge huge fan of Matt and
I loved the Batman just loved thank you
and yeah Mike's amazing I mean again you
know it's not like you go into a
numbness when you're there because you
forget like you know you're just working
with again but another I'm not a great
director I would communicating with what
he wants in in the most delicate way and
making you understand
um and and that's the most important
thing for me is being able to understand
what my director wants and
but he's just amazed and he was so on
board with me and same with Dylan Clark
and and getting to do the scene with Rob
um you know Robin and Paul Daniel was
just again master classes you know were
you happy that that deleted EXT like
that deleted scene got released because
it was you know yeah like I mean that's
a big scene to get you know to get cut
no yeah very you know you always want
your you your work to get released you
know if it makes sense but again they
wouldn't release if they didn't think it
made sense and again I just wanted
people to kind of see my take on it and
you know and I'm blessed as well that I
got to you know do a portrayal of that I
have to ask you what is it like playing
an iconic character like that in terms
of what you're reading and what you're
watching before stepping on set because
the amount of you know many people have
done the role and everyone has a
different take on it and there's no
right or wrong it's just your
interpretation of this iconic character
again yeah it is it's very very
intimidating you know
um heat Ledger was the best for me he's
just
yeah and so you know you've a lot of
people to to draw from and then and that
but again you know no like
you know you bring your version too and
that's one little bit any character will
play is no one to see my version of it
and again going back to I don't want to
be like so and so and you know follow
that method and that method I want to do
me I want to bring my version because
I feel that is new in a way and and
unique
and that when you bring your version
known as Cena and that may make people
relate to it or you know yeah so it was
intimidating but you know I was excited
for it yeah I I think the Batman's one
of the best films of the year I think
Matt just destroyed it and also G Aquino
soundtrack the way you use the Nirvana
song like the Pattinson's performance
list goes on and on I can just keep on
you know um uh the cinematography I can
keep going right yeah what was it like
for you being a part of a movie like
that and watching it for the first time
are you able to enjoy it as like an
audience member or are you just thinking
about you know what I mean like how is
it yeah and I mean watching any movie
you're a part of is quite hard you know
I bet when you watch you know these
clips back it's hard to look at yourself
right or even listen to yourself and but
yeah it's a learning experience you you
watch you watch movies but you learn and
you know and I don't ever watch a movie
and be like yes nailed it or you know
you obviously look at the film as a
whole as well but I'm constantly
learning on what I can make a bit more
truthful or what I could have done or
and not to be too critical upon yourself
either but just kind of you know to to
make it a learning experience and not
dissect it too much sure I loved
promising young women
um Emerald is obviously such a talent
behind the camera
um yeah what was it like working have
you touched on it a little bit that you
prepared a lot for the role what was it
like working with her and what can you
tease about the movie
it's just amazing I really mean that I
had a lot a lot of fun with her and I'm
such a great person as well always there
for me and has been
um and just you know and she's an
actress she gets it you know she gets it
she really does so when you have a
problem or when you you know she's just
I really mean that she's by your side
you know she's dragging you through it
she's like let's do it we're doing it
together and so it's a really
collaborative experience that I felt
like you know we were in it together
and because she she totally understands
that I think it's going to be you know
it this script was just amazing and you
know she's done a great [ __ ] job yeah
I don't want to give too much away and
under cinematography as well you know
Nina's
um
just it just looks like and looks like a
paint and I can't wait I mean seriously
but for anyone who's really amazing let
me tell you yeah no promising young
woman's incredible and so obviously
that's like a like a a [ __ ] great
movie and so obviously I want to see
whatever she's going to do next
um what are you thinking about do you
already know what you're doing in the in
the coming months or the coming year in
terms of the work you're getting ready
to do well I just yeah I'm being quite
picky you know and I I think
I I just want to be yeah I want to be
very very selective on what I do and you
know I never kind of Chase projects for
certain reasons other than you know is
there something challenging there for me
or can I do something fresh with it or
you know I really like this director or
Etc but um I've got a son now Brando and
he's eight weeks old and then
congratulations thank you and we had him
on
5th of August when I was filming and
nice shoots it was all born and uh he's
just amazed and we went to the cinema
last night in New York we only got
passport so we went to the cinema last
night
force them and sentiment and on the wall
was Brando the name Brando
wow honestly it was just like he's not
going to be an actor I'm not hey he's
not gonna be an actor no way but um I
think spend time with my son and I'm
excited for that you know it's a whole
new experience and
and but in terms of what I'm gonna do
next
yeah
I'll leave it there listen man I really
mean it congrats on everything that's
been happening I always talk to you you
know you're a legend I don't know about
that but I'm gonna say that I really do
appreciate the amount of time today and
um I you know whatever I can do to help
you promote your work uh let me know
because we have at least 10 followers on
Collider
we're doing okay
your election man your electric going
back to the Dunkirk days Legend yeah
completely Hey listen um thank you so
much for real and uh good luck with the
rest of your speed dating today go on
thank you have a good day